do you want to get started with your day
I'm here whatever you want me to do Kris
Jenner is putting Khloe Kardashian to
work I worked so hard on the latest
episode of Keeping Up with the
Kardashians
Khloe swings by Kylie cosmetics to be
her mama Jers personal assistant I got
my assistant shoes on I got my fanny
pack I'm ready to go hands-free I'm here
to help and make Chris Turner's life a
breeze but can Coco keep up with Chris
Chloe Chloe also Chloe Chloe Chloe is it
me or are we getting Devil Wears Prada
vibes
there's some reason that my coffee isn't
here has she died or something Chloe
this coffee isn't hot at all Emily how
many times do I have to scream your name
yeah chris is 100% Miranda Priestly
that's huh from checking off her mom's
to-do list I need you to put together
some of the promo kits for Kylie
cosmetics and for Kylie skin can I get
the agenda for the meeting with Jen and
Megha take these two packets and scan
them over to production for me to
catering her daily priorities why don't
you bring my luncheon and make sure you
record date lines we have to admit Chloe
is killing her new temp job I was really
proud of myself but it's Chris's next
request that had me saying seriously I
need you to go through all of these
snacks and then let's see what's fresh
but I like you personally to eat every
single one of those items this is a job
I can do very well same girl same oh
those are stale that's fresh that's good
crunchy is still good so fresh okay
oh yeah have more of these trying to
take the job honestly where do I sign up
this day has been off to a fabulous
start I love the hustle and bustle I'm
on top of things I'm just great at it
oh the hustle and bustle is rough this
is a job I couldn't do very well but I'm
here for it I don't know if she's just
like in with me but whatever Chris
Turner wants she again
[Music]